شكرا لزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مستمرون في تغطيتنا
للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان
ففي الوقت الذي تبادل فيه الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع على الاتهامات بشان خرق هدنه
الايام الثلاثه افاد مراسل العربيه بان
المدنيين يواجهون صعوبات في الخروج من
مناطق الاشتباكات في الخرطوم ومع استمرار
المواجهات تتزايد المخاوف من انهيار
النظام الصحي هناك بشكل كامل
لقد خرجنا الحمد لله رب العالمين سالمين
هذه السفينه من بورسودان الى جده حرب
ضاحنه قويه حقيقه
هذا واصدر الجيش السوداني بيانا شجب خلاله
الخروقات العديده التي اقترفها الدعم
السريع للهدنه حسب تعبيره
الجيش السوداني قال ان مجموعات الدعم
السريع تواصل تحركاتها داخل وخارج الخرطوم
برغم الهدنه
حيث رصد الجيش تحركات لارتال عسكريه متجهه
من غرب السودان الى الخرطوم اضافه الى
محاولات مجموعات من الدعم السريع السيطره
على مصفى الجيل للتحكم بالوقود
الجيش السوداني اتهم ايضا الدعم السريع
باستغلال الهدنه لانقاذ موقفها العمليتي
الذي وصفه بالمتدهور عبر نشر قناصه في
الخرطوم وولايات اخرى
[موسيقى]
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع قوات
الجيش باستهداف مواقعها قرب القصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم
وقال بيان الدعم السريع ان هذا الاستهداف
يعد انتهاكا للهدنه المعلنه مؤكدان ان
القصف العشوائي للجيش يهدد حياه المدنيين
ورعايا الدول الاجانب في الخرطوم
كما اشارت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان الله
الى ان كسر شروط الهدنه المعلنه يؤكد وجود
اكثر من مركز قرار داخل قياده الجيش
واعادت دعم السريع التاكيد على التزامه
بشروط الهدنه لفتح ممرات الانسانيه
للمدنيين والمقيمين
معي من مركز الروبي الطبي بامدرمان مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم جديد المشهد من
عندك اخر التطورات تحديدا الوضع
الاستشفائي كونك متواجد في مركز الرومي
الطبي بام درمان
في مستشفى
وقعت شظايا داخل هذا المستشفى المؤدي الى
اصابه اكثر من 13 شخصا بجروح في الارجل
بشكل مختلف ثم نقلهم بعدها على ابرهه الى
مستشفى هذا المستشفى كان خارج الخدمه الى
يوم امس تم بدا العمل فيه يوم امس وبدا في
عمله هذه في اثر الحملات التي كانت
متواصله من لجنه اطباء السودان المركزيه
وكذلك بقيه العاملين في الحقل الصحي وهم
يطالبون بفتح المستشفيات يثرها جاء هذا
الفتح لهذا المستشفى بدا عمله وبعدها ذلك
اليوم او اصابتهم شظايا ادت الى اصابه
ثلاثه عشر شخصا او اكثر من ذلك
الان يتحدث المواطنون هنا ان هناك ايضا
شظائع وقعت في مكان اخر لكنه لم تصل اي
احد بالاما زلنا في انتظار ان ننظر الى
مكان هذا الامر هذه الشظائر ربما جاءت من
مبادئه للطيران لا
يعرف طبعا من الذي اطلق هذه الشظائف لكن
بكل تاكيد الذي سمعناه في الايام الماضيه
وكذلك من
هذه الشظائف شظائر مضاده الطائرات هي عند
قوات الدعم السريع بكثافه وانها تستخدم
كثيرا لكن الى هذه اللحظه لم يثبت شيء في
هذا الامر
سالم هل المستشفى يعمل بكامل طاقته وما هو
ما هي قدرته الاستيعابيه وهل الادويه
متوافره في المشفى ام لا
اما بدايه بالحديث هناك في بعض الادويه
وهذا واضح اذا تابعنا الكثير من النداءات
التي تطلق بين الحين والاخرى عن الحديث عن
بعض الادويه بدات تبحث في الصيدليات هذه
واحده ثانيا اما بالنسبه للقدره
الاستيعابيه لهذا المستشفى فهو مستشفى ليس
مستشفى كبير لكنه مستوصف وله فرعين
متقابلين او مبنيين متقابلين لكنه كان
كافيا للاحياء القريبه من هذه المنطقه في
الثورات ويرتاده العديد من المرضى خاصه
وانه في يومه الاول لاحظ كل الذين
استطلعناهم الان اقبالا على هذا المستشفى
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالحالات البارده التي
ظلت منذ عشره ايام لا تعمل فيها الكثير من
المستشفيات ربما بدا هذا المستشفى بحكم
انه بعيد عن المناطق التي تشتد فيها
الاشتباكات وهذا مهم ايضا لنضيفه هذا
المستشفى يقع في كان الكثيرون يظنون انها
بعيده كل البعد عن مرمى النيران بعيده عن
الاصابات بل هذه المنطقه ربما شهدت
نزوحا كذلك من المواطنين من مدينه الخرطوم
ومن مدينه بحر جاءنا هذه المنطقه بحكم
انها منطقه امنه وهي الان بهذه الشظائف
وربما هي رساله الى انه ليس هنالك امن ما
دام هذا السلاح يطلق في الهواء عدد الجرحى
الذين نقلوا الى المستشفى منذ الامس اذا
كان لديك ارقام سالم وما هي مستويات
جراحاتهم اذا كان لديك معلومات هذه الجراح
كانت اليوم قبل قليل التي تحدثنا عنها 13
شخص الذين اصيبوا الان وربما اكثر لان هذا
العدد ليس بدقيق لكن اقله 13 شخصا تم نقله
الى مستشفى وهذا مؤكد اصابتهم ليست بالغه
بحسب الافادات لانها اغلبها في الارجل لان
هذه الشظايا وقعت
مباشره في الارض وتشتت بعد ذلك على ارجل
الجالسين وكان مجموعه من المرضى في انتظار
ان ياتيهم الدور للدخول الى الطبيب وهذه
المنطقه التي وقعت فيها الشظائف هي الصاله
التي يجلس فيها المرضى الانتظار دورهم
للدخول الى الاطباء وهذا ما تحدثت عنه قبل
قليل بانه بدا هذا المستشفى في استقبال
الحراره البارده وليست طوارئ وهو مستشفى
مختص بهذا الامر مختص بالحالات البارده
فيه معمل وفيه العديد من الاطباء
والمستشفى بمختلف التخصصات لكنه ليس
المستشفى الكبير الضخم هو مستشفى اقرب
لمستشفيات الاحياء وهو يغطي هذه الاحياء
القريبه من هنا والعديد من المرضى جاءوا
الى هذا المستشفى بحثا عن العلاج وجلسوا
وجاءت هذه الشظائف ربما هذه الشظايا ربما
يفهم منها وهي الرساله الاكبر في هذا
الامر بعد الاستهداف للمستشهاد بكل تاكيد
في الفترات الماضيه
من مستشفى لاخر يفهم من ذلك انه يمكن ان
لا يكون هنالك مكان امن مادام هنالك اسلحه
في الجو تستخدم بهذا الشكل
وتعرض حياه المدنيين لخطر دون يعني
الاستعداد لهذا الخبر حتى هل يسمع اي
اصوات لطلقات ناريه
لرصاص في هذه الاثناء او سمعت تناها الى
ما سامعك اصوات اطلاق نار ام لا ثم التزام
تام او شبه تام بالهدنه سالم
نعم الهدنه مثل الهدف السابقه بالضبط
بانها تعلن ثم بعد ذلك يتم اختراقها
بمختلف انواع الاسلحه لكن ربما هذه المره
اختراق الفيلم باصابات للاسف هذا اليوم
الثاني الذي نشهد فيه اصابات بمدنيين من
مرامي النيران المختلفه
وامر حتى الهلع
الامر مزعج جدا بالنسبه لهم هنا بالنسبه
لاسم الاصوات
وكذلك الطيران كان يسمع منذ صباح او منذ
ظهر اليوم بالتحديد بعد 12 سمع اصوات
متفرقه في مناطق كذلك متفرقه من ولايه
الخرطوم ابرزها محيط لدعوه التلفزيون
وكذلك محيط القياده العامه للجيش ايضا بعض
المناطق المتفرقه حتى هذه اللحظه هذا هو
الوضع الميداني بالنسبه الى الكهرباء
الماء الانترنت لو تعطينا ايجاز سالم عن
هذه الامور الحياتيه يعني والضروريه جدا
هل الكهرباء ما زالت مقطوعه عن الخرطوم
ماذا عن مياه الشفا وكذلك الانترنت
بالنسبه نبدا بالمياه لانها معضله حقيقيه
ظل يشكو منها العديد من المواطنين في
احياء متفرقه من ولايه الخرطوم ابرزها
مدينه بحري وهي التي تتصدر الان مشهد غياب
خدمه المياه
منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات ويعني لجوء
المواطنين
المناطق متفرقه من مدينه بحري حتى هذه
اللحظه موقف المياه في مدينه بحري كما هو
مدينه ايضا منطقه صالحه في اندرمان كما هو
مناطق متفرقه من جبره وبعض الخلافه
ايضا في ام درمان هناك مناطق متفرقه منها
صالحه مثلا وما هو بالقرب من محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون هنالك ايضا احياء تغيب عنها
المياه حتى هذه اللحظه الكهرباء كذلك
منطقه صالحه ام درمان كهرباء منذ اول يوم
الاشتباك الكهرباء بالاضافه الى بعض
المناطق التي تتذبذب فيها الكهرباء في
مدينه بحري في احياء الشعبيه وكذلك
الصافيه في هذه المناطق
ربما هناك مساعي من ولايه الخرطوم من اجل
ارجاع هذه الخدمه لكن ظل هناك تبادل
للاتحامات ما بين المكونين من ان خدمه
المياه هي مسؤوليه كذلك الطرف هو من
يحاصرها لكن بكل تاكيد ان ولايه الخرطوم
كانت قد بارجاع خدمه المياه وايصال خدمه
الكهرباء بعنايه لكن الى هذه اللحظه لم
توفق في كل الاجراءات وفقه جزئيا في بعض
المناطق وبعض المناطق ما زالت تغيب عن هذه
الخدمات بالنسبه للانترنت للغايه في مختلف
انحاء السودان في مختلف السودان هنالك
هنالك تذبذب واضح
في خدمه الانترنت ويجعل صعوبه التواصل
فيما بيننا حتى نحن الان ونحن نقدم هذه
الخدمات الاخباريه نعاني جدا من انقطاع
خدمات الانترنت به كذلك
من مركز الرومي الطبي بي ام درمان في
الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي شكرا
جزيلا لك سالم على كل هذه المتابعه
وبعد اتهامات الجيش لقوات الدعم السريع
بانها تستهدف البعثات الدبلوماسيه قالت
قوات الدعم السريع انها تنسق مع البعثات
الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه
ما اسهم في اجراء الرعايه الى اماكن امنه
واكد بيان الدعم السريع انه متمسكون
بالهدنه مشيرا الى ان هذا الالتزام نابع
من مسؤوليتها الاخلاقيه والتزامها للدول
التي طالبت بتجديد الهدنه لفتح ممرات
انسانيه
هذا ونشرت قوات الدعم السريع صورا لما
قالت انه تامين الشاحنات المصريه بمنطقه
قريه الحره شمال الخرطوم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نحن الان في السوق
الحر لمنطقه قريه
هذه الشاحنات طبعا شاحنات مصريه مع
اخواننا المصريين الان يعني قوات الدعم
السريع تؤمن كل هذا السوق والبترول ونحن
الان يعني حتى اخواننا المصريين معنا هنا
فنسمع منه يعني
كلمه حق يعني اتجاه القوات الدعم السريع
وتامين لهم وحتى هم معانا الان يعني
ياتي ذلك في وقت نشد فيه عدد من المواطنين
في السودان عبر كاميرا العربيه جميع
الاطراف في السودان لوقف القتال وتامين
احتياجات المواطنين وتامين المحال
التجاريه التي تعرضت للنهب والسلب خلال
الاشتباكات لا
للسرغراميه
نحن
غيرك بانه الناس الشعب السوداني تعب لانه
حاصل غلاء في الوطن السودان في غلاء شديد
لا في مويه لا في كهرباء الناس متجهه
لبخاع السودان نسبه لضيق عن معيشه في
البلد وعدم توفر الامان ما شايف شرطي واحد
في الشارع لو نزلت الشرطه امنت المواطنين
نزلته البنزين نزلته كل الناس هترتاح
العنصريه نتكلم عن الجنسيه السودانيه وفقط
ونتكلم عن انسان سوداني انسان سوداني
محترم لا يقبل لا يقبل عن يميد يده لحق
غيره نتكلم عن الحوادث السالبه اللي حصلت
في المحنه دي لا لا للحرب
قررت حكومه شمال كردفان وسط السودان فرض
حظر تجوين الليلي بالولايه بالولايه
ابتداء من الساعه العاشره مساء وحتى
الخامسه صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي
ودعا والي الولايه فضل الله التوم الى
تضافر الجهود والعمل من اجل تحقيق الامن
والاستقرار والسلم المجتمعي وخلال اجتماعا
ضم لجنه امن الولايه واعضاء حكومتها وجهها
المجتمعون بتقديم الدعم والاسناد اللازم
للجيش
وحول الرعايه الذين تم اجلاؤهم من السودان
اعلن الناطق الرسمي باسم وزاره الخارجيه
وشؤون المغتربين في الاردن سنان المجالي
اعلن عن وصول اربع طائرات تابعه لسلاح
الجو الملكي الاردني الى مطار ماركا
العسكري في عمان تحمل على متنها اكثر من
300 مواطن اردني ورعايا من بلدان مختلف
لما وصلنا مطار بور سودان شفنا طياراتنا
الحلوه هذه وجيشنا الحلو وكل التعب راح
للاسف معظم المعارك حاليا بين المدنيين
بالاحياء فخطير خطير جدا بس ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله انه ما يروح لاكثر من هيك
طريق من الخرطوم لبورسودان تقريبا اخذت
معنا محدوده 38 ساعه بين الجبال وبين
الشوارع ونقاط تفتيش وهذا يوقف وهذا يمشي
وهذا يوقف شوي واضح عطله الوضع الله يكون
بالعون يعني بساوي للاسف ما اساوي حرب
شوارع عرفت كيف
قتلى اموات في الشوارع ما في امان نهائيا
يعني عمليه التصويب ما بتكون على اشخاص
يعني الربيع عشوائي على الناس حتى
استنفار دبلوماسي في شتى الدول الاثر
اشتباكات السودان
عمليات اجلاء الرعايه على قدم وساق
الولايات المتحده اجلت 100 شخص بثلاث
مروحيات حلقت من جيبوتي مرورا باثيوبيا
وصولا الى السودان
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه والامنيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال ان اكثر
من الف من رعايانا غادر السودان فرنسا
اجلت ما يقارب
538 فردا بينهم اوروبيون وافارقه اما
ايطاليا فاغلقت سفارتها في الخرطوم وطلبت
من 200 شخص ترك الاراضي السودانيه في حين
تنتظر المانيا وصول طائره رابعه للاجلاء
مع ايصال 500 شخص الى بر الامان واجلت
طائره اسبانيه 100 شخص بينهم 30 اسبانيا
وسبعون من اوروبا وامريكا اللاتينيه
وايرلندا بواقع 150 شخصا كما تم اجلاء نحو
25 نمساويا
وتسعه رومانيين وخمسه مجريين وواحد وعشرين
بلغاريا بمساعده دول اخرى
اذهب الى الخرطوم المزيد من المتابع انضم
الي الصحفي شهد نادر اهلا وسهلا بك الى
هذه التغطيه جديد المشهد الميداني هل
هنالك التزام تام بوقف اطلاق النار ام لا
ثمت خروقات وفق متابعتك
مرحبا نعم هناك
خروقات مستمره منذ صباحها هذا اليوم تجددت
الاشتباكات وتحديدا في منطقه درمان وكذلك
في شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري هذا ما قصدناه
هذه الخروقات اسفل عن سقوط عدد من
المغذوفات داخل احياء السكنيه احداهما
اصابه
مركز طبيا كان يقدم خدمات علاجيه ستانفه
عمله يوم امس ولكن اليوم سقط عليه مغضوب
ليخرجهم من الخدمه مخلفا وراءه اكثر من
عشره
اصابات تم تحويلها الى المستشفى الذي يكاد
يكون وحيدا الذي استانف عمله في هذه
المنطقه هو مستشفى انه كذلك هناك بعض
المناوشات في منطقه وسط العاصمه بحسب ما
افادت شهود عيان وايضا جنوبي مدينه
انظر معا الطرفي لا صراع اليوم الزرابه
يعني تبادلات فيه الاتهامات بان كل طرف قد
تاخرك الهدنه ولكن رغم كل ذلك اليوم هناك
هدوء حذر حركه المواطنين
بدات شيئا فشيئا معتزال عمليات
النزوح مستمره
الى خارج العاصمه البعض يختار ولايات
مجاوره والبعض اثر ان يقادر خارجا خارج
السودان الى جمهوريه مصر العربيه الى
اثيوبيا وخلافه طيب السيد شهدي وانت تتحدث
هذه الاخبار العاجله اعزائي المشاهدين
ترون على الشاشه قوات الدعم السريع تقول
انها توجهت القاده الميدانيين للتعامل مع
النهب
والتخريب طيب بالنسبه الى عمليات السلب
والنهب والتخريب هل فعلا يسجل مثل هكذا
حالات تحديدا في ام درمان ام لا الامر
مقتصر على مناطق اخرى سيد شهدي
نعم من واقع الملاحظه وحديث مع الاطباء
اليوم في مستشفى النوم هناك ارتفاع ملحوظ
لحالات الطعن بالات حاده كل 60 بدات تريدي
الى المستشفى منذ حوالي اربعه ايام يقولون
انها تمضي في ازدياد اليوم في جنوب شرق
الخرطوم وتحديدا في ضاحيه سوبا اودت بحياه
هض الاطباء المشهورين الدكتور عوض ابن عوف
استشاري الباطنيه طعن قادره فيه العنقي
والصدق اودت بحياته هناك اعمال سلب ونهب
بدات لها اكثر من ايام وتمضي فيه ازدياد
اظنك اظنك شاهدت يوم عينك حالات النهب
التي تعرضت لها في مستودعات
الخبز في منطقه الخرطوم بحري وعدد من
المصانع النعم عاده المجموعات التي تعرف
شعبيا هنا في السودان ب 9 طويله الى انتاج
مكانه
من عمليات نهب تحت تحديد السلاح هذه هذه
الظاهره تنظيفي ازدياد بشكل كبير في ظل
الدوله وانشقال القوات المسلحه في الدعم
السريع باختتالهم في ظل غياب
قوات الشرطه عن المشهد عدم نزولها الى
الشوارع حتى هذه حتى هذه اللحظه التي
اتحدث فيها معك
بالنسبه الى حركه النزوح ماذا يمكن ان
نقول اليوم عن حركه النزوح تحديدا من
الخرطوم العاصمه
نعم هذه الحركه هي مستمره ولم تتوقف اسعار
فلكيه وصلت في مايلي اسعار التذاكر اصحاب
الشركات الباصات السفريه كما تعلم بان
السفر جوا متوقف بشكل كلي بعد استهداف
مطار الخرطوم وتوقف حركه الملاحه الجويه
منذ الى هذه الاحداث ارقام التذاكر وصلت
لارقام فلكيه تضاعفت سعر التذكره بنسبه
1000% او 1500
بالمئه ولكن رغم ذلك ما يزال كثير من
السودانيين
يقادرون العاصمه الى ولايات مجاوره وكذلك
الى دول مجاوره
طيب بالعوده الى موضوع الخروقات هل يمكن
التثبت من ان الخروقات تاتي من طرف واحد
ام لا الخرقات يمكن القول انها تاتي من
الطرفين هل هذا صحيح
الطرف عند الله على الدوام يتبادلان
الاتهامات عبر بيانات تصدر من كل الطرف
حينما يحدث اخره اوقات شاهدنا بيان للدعم
السريعي القوات المسلحه وكذلك القوات
المسلحه اتحمت الدعم السريع قالنا كل
الطرفين يدفع بالتهمه الى الاخر بانه
المتسبب هذا الامر
منذ الله الهدنه الاولى التي كانت بثلاث
ساعات حينما تم اعلان اول هدنه وفشلت فشلت
اثريه قال كثيرون من المختصين انه لابد من
تشكيل اهليه لابد من تحديد طرق امنه لابد
من ان هذه الهدنه تحتاج لمطلوبات من غير
متوفره حتى هذه اللحظه لابد من تشكيل اليه
تنزل الى الارض لابد لتحديد سيارات معين
عليه تقوم بازلاء جرحى توصل للخدمات توصل
للمواد الاساسيه للمواطنين المواد الطبيه
للمستشفيات تساعد الاطباء على الوصول الى
المشافي في قياف هذه الاليه اجتمعت ان
تنجح اي هدنه او انتن ان تتماسك بقدر يجعل
السودانيين قادرين على ان يتحركوا ان
تصلهم
الخدمات والمواد التي تساعدهم على العيش
مثل هذه الظروف سيد شهدي ارجو ان تبقى معي
ساسالك بعد قليل عن موضوع الاحتياجات
الانسانيه تحديدا اذا ما كان هنالك ازمه
خبز ولكن اعزائي المشاهدين هذه الصور
تاتينا الان لاستهداف الجيش السوداني
لاحدى دوريات قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
الحلفايه اذا هذه صور تردنا لاستهداف
الجيش
لدوريه من دوريات قوات الدعم السريع في
منطقه الحلفايه
واعود واذكر بالخبر العاجل ان قوات الدعم
السريع تقول انها وجهت القاده الميدانيين
للتعامل مع حالات النهب والتخريب بالطبع
العاصمه الخرطوم شهدت اعمال نهب وسلب
كبيره نتيجه
بفعل هذا الاقتتال وهذه المواجهات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
يعني عشرات المتاجر تم نهبها وسلبها
في اكثر من منطقه في العاصمه السودانيه
اعود الى شهد نادر سيد شهدي بالنسبه الى
الاحتياجات الانسانيه وموضوع الخبز سلعه
الخبز والطحين هل يعني
متوافره ام لا يعني هنالك صعوبه كبيره في
تامين ماده الطحين وبالتالي الخبز
نعم هي هذا الامر هو متفاوت من منطقه الى
اخرى هناك مناطق كما تعلم بان في كل
المحليه مستودع او مخزن يضم اطنان كبيره
من ما تستهلكه مواطنها المحليه في بعض
المناطق هناك وفره هناك ما يزال
متوفر او متيسر او ميسر بعض الشيء ولكن في
في مناطق اخرى يقف المواطنون لساعات طوال
من اجل الحصول على الخبز
كثيره جدا خرجت عن الخدمه لاسباب متفاوته
من ضمنها الدقيق دقيق الخوص ولكن هناك ثمه
اسباب اخرى انها عدم توفر الغاز عدم
توفرها الديزل انقطاع خدمات الكهرباء
والمياه كلها اسباب ساهمت في خروج كثير
جدا من
المخازن وبالاضافه الى الضعف في امداد
امداد القمح الدقيقه المستقر لهذه
المخابز ايضا الوضع الانساني الوضع
الانساني الرغم ان هناك مجهودات تنزيلها
سواء السلطات الرسميه او متطوعين وجمعيات
ام متطوعه ومراكز خاصه ولكن هذا الاستهداف
عدم وجود
عدم اغرار الهدنه بشكل فعلي يعيق مثلا
امداد المستشفيات ما تحتاجه من مواد حتى
يتسنى لها التعامل معه اي حاله ترده اليها
صعوبات واجه الله
الاطباء في الوصول للمستشفيات وكذلك
المرضى منهم درمان الصحفي شهد نادر شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد شهري على هذه المشاركه عبر
قناه العربي
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليبرلي
انه تحدث مع طرفي الصراع في السودان مؤكدا
انه سيواصل الضغط على القوتين من اجل
الالتزام بوقف دائم لاطلاق النار
لقد تحدثت بشكل مباشر ومن خلال وسطاء مع
الاطراف المتصارعه وقمت بدعوتهم الى
السماح باجلاء المواطنين البريطانيين
ومزدوجه الجنسيه والاطفال وسنواصل الضغط
من اجل الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار بالطبع
من المستحيل ان نتنبا بالوقت الذي سيستمر
فيه الهدوء ونحن ندعو مواطنينا الى ترك
الاولويه للاشد حاجه الى الاجلاء
قال ايضا ان الوضع ما يزال خطيرا ومتقلبا
ولا يمكن التنبؤ به في السودان
بالعصيده
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه قمنا بتخطيط
مكثف عبر الادارات الحكوميه ومع شركائنا
الدوليين للاستفاده من اي تحسن في الوضع
على الارض للبدء في اجلاء الرعايه
البريطانيين في السودان يسعدني جدا اعلان
وقف اطلاق النار من قبل قاده الفصائل على
الارض وبال بدانا عمليات الاجلاء من المهم
ان نتذكر انه تم خرق كل اعلانات وقف اطلاق
النار سابقا وبالتالي فان الوضع لا يزال
خطيرا ومتقلبا ولا يمكن التنبؤ به
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء التي تقوم
بها الدول الغربيه من السودان قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الالمانيه انها لا تخطط للمزيد
من رحلات الاجلاء الالمانيه من البلاد
مشيره الى ان اخر رحله اجلاء من السودان
الى الاردن ستنطلق مساء اليوم
واوضحت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان دولا شريكه
ستتولى اجلاء المواطنين الالمان المتبقين
في السودان خلال الايام المقبله
اما فرنسا فاعلنت انتهاء عمليه الاجلاء
نحو جيبوتي وقالت هيئه اركان الجيوش
الفرنسيه انها ابقت على فرغاتها في
بورتسودان لمساعده الامم المتحده في عمليه
الاجلاء نحو جده كما اكلت وزاره الخارجيه
والدفاع الفرنسيه في بيان مشترك ان عدد
الجنسيات التي استفادت من عمليات الاجلاء
الفرنسيه ارتفع الى 41 جنسيا واشار البيان
الى ان عمليات الاجلاء حصلت من نقاط
التجمع في الخرطوم نحو قاعده وادي سيدنا
ومن القاعده جوا الى جيبوتي
الى فريش الان مراسل العربيه حسين فنادق
نايبر يتابع عمليات الاجلاء التي تقوم بها
الخارجيه الفرنسيه حسين اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد عمليات الاجلاء وكم
اصبحت الارقام وهل هنالك اي رحلات مجدوله
في الايام المقبله
اهلا بك طالب دعني اشير بدايه الى ان ما
ذكرته عن عمليات اجلاء اوروبيه من بينها
ما تقوم به المانيا وبريطانيا وايضا
عمليات الاجلاء الاخرى الايطاليه
والاسبانيه والسويسريه وغيرها هذه
العمليات لا يمكن مقارنتها بعمليه الاجلاء
الفرنسيه التي قد تكون الاوسع نطاقا على
المستوى الاوروبي على الاقل من السودان
حتى الان وصل عدد الذين اجلتهم فرنسا
538 شخصا من بينهم
والمجموع ينتمي الى احدى واربعين جنسيه
عده دول اوروبيه حتى تلك التي تقوم
بعمليات اجلاء محدوده خصوصا من بين الدول
الاوروبيه طلبت ايضا من فرنسا المساعده
بالنظر الى وجود عسكري فرنسي في المنطقه
تحديدا في جيبوتي فرنسا اعلنت ان الدول
التي استفادت من عمليات الاجلاء
هي هولندا ايسلندا فنلندا ايرلندا السويد
الدنمارك النرويج بلجيكا المانيا النمسا
سويسرا ايطاليا البرتغال واليونان هنغاريا
ورومانيا اجليا ايضا عدد كبير من مواطني
الدول الافريقيه من بينها النيجر ونيجيريا
وتشاد وبوروندي وكينيا ومن السودان نفسها
كما اجلي عدد من المواطنين المصريين
والمغاربه واجلي مواطنون من كندا
واستراليا واليابان والهند والفلبين عدد
كبير اذا من الدول الطلبه المساعده من
فرنسا التي تواصل عمليات الاجلاء التي
شارفت على نهايتها كما قالت مصادر وزارتي
الدفاع والخارجيه توجد على الارض في
السودان قوات فرنسيه طالب تتولى الاستطلاع
والحمايه لضمان امن الذين ينتقلون من نقاط
التجمع عند مشارف الخرطوم نحو قاعده في
وادي سيدنا التي تبعد حوالي عشرين كيلو
مترا عن الخرطوم ومن هناك يسار الى نقل
الذين يراد اجلائهم جوا من القاعده الجويه
في وادي سيدنا السودانيه نحو فرنسا قالت
انها ابقت على الفرقه لورين امام ميناء
بورسودان لمساعده الامم المتحده على
مواصله عمليات الاجلاء الامميه من
بورسودان نحو جده في السعوديه طالب حسين
هل بقي اي دبلوماسي فرنسي في الخرطوم او
في السودان عموما وفق المعلومات ام لا
يعني لن يبقى اي دبلوماسي
كل الطاقم الدبلوماسي الفرنسي بمن فيه
السفيره الفرنسيه في الخرطوم غادر الى
جيبوتي تمهيدا لانتقاله الى باريس حتى ان
الطاقم الدبلوماسي التابع اللي بعثه
الاتحاد الاوروبي في السودان شملته ايضا
عمليات الاجلاء الفرنسيه السفيره الفرنسيه
في الخرطوم ستواصل عملها من هنا من باريس
وستواصل فرنسا عبر مركز الازمات والدعم
الذي تواجدت فيه العربيه امس لمواكبه
التواصل بين الخارجيه الفرنسيه
وجيبوتي وايضا السودان مركز الازمات
والدعم هذا سيواصل عمله في الايام المقبله
لانجاز عمليه الاجلاء التي قالت لنا
الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الى اقصى حدود على الارض لانه كان يجب
التواصل مع الاطراف السودانيه ودبلوماسيا
لانه كان يجب القيام باتصالات مع عدد كبير
من الدول من بينها السعوديه ومصر
والامارات ومع الامم المتحده ومع الاتحاد
الاوروبي والاتحاد الافريقي والدول الخمس
الدائمه العضويه في مجلس الامن وايضا
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا بالمناسبه 12
مواطنا بريطانيا وتسعه امريكيين وخمسه
بولنديين استفادوا من عمليات الاجلاء
الفرنسيه الواسعه النطاق طالب من باريس
مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا حسين فنادق
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
النزوح بات الحل امام الكثير من
السودانيين هرب من الاقتتال الدائر الامر
الذي دفع مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين للتعبير عن قلقها من فرار اكثر
من 200 الف شخص الى تشاد وجنوب السودان
وقالت ممثله المفوضيه في تشاد لورا
لوكاسترو انه وصل الى البلاد 20 الف لاجئ
حتى الان ومن المتوقع ان يتبعهم مئه الف
اخرون مشيره الى دخول 170 الف شخص الى
جنوب السودان منذ بدء هذه المواجهه
ناكل ونشربه
كثير وما نقدر نرجع قدام هذه حاجات
ولانهم اكل ولا شرف
وعلى الحدود السودانيه المصريه تستمر
عمليات الاجلاء لالاف من المصريين
والسودانيين عبر معبر ارقين البري حيث
افادت وسائل الاعلام المصريه عن وصول ما
يقرب من خمسه الاف شخص بين مصريين
وسودانيين ومن جنسيات اخرى عبر هذا المعبر
الله يجعل طويله طويله جدا هاي الرحله
كانت
كلها مخاطر وكده
وضارب شديد حاصل
في ضرب في الطريق
في الخروج ووسط اصوات انفجار عنيفه وسط
اصوات رصاص قرر بانه يبعد باولاده عن
اماكن النزع بين القوات المسلحه وبين قوات
الدعم السريع
ومش كان بيقولوا في ودنه لكن حتى الهدنه
كان في حرق واضح لها يعني الواحد يتمنى
انه الحرب ينتهي وانه يرجع الامن والامان
اذهب الى القاهره ينضم اليه من هناك
السفير صلاح حليمه وهو مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الاسبق ورئيس مكتب الجامعه
العربيه في السودان سابقا ساعات سفير اهلا
وسهلا بك اولا ما هو تقييمك لوقف اطلاق
النار هل تعتقد انه سيصمد هذه المره ام لا
عاجلا ام اجلا سيكون اينا للسقوط
في تقدير ان هذه الهدنه مثل
سوابقها ليس هناك ما يؤكد او يضمن وقفه
اطلاق النار بشكل دائم على الرغم من ان
النداءات لوقفه اطلاق النار تصدر من كافه
الدول المنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه في هذا
السطر انا في تقديري ان كل هذه النداءات
لا جدوى منها ما لم يكن هناك يعني رؤيه
تقضي بضروره ان تكون هناك اليه لمراقبه
وقف اطلاق النار والتدقيق وقف اطلاق النار
عاده يختلف عن وقف العدائيات وقف اطلاق
النار يحتاج الى اليه للمراقبه هذا امر
يجب ايضا ان يقترن بان العمليه ليست فقط
وقف اطلاق النار لاعتبارات انسانيه تتيح
بموجبها فرصه للناجحين واللاجئين بان
يغادروا البلد وانما ايضا يجب ان يكون
هناك استكمال لذلك بان يكون هناك ايضا
وفود او جلب مساعدات للمستشفيات وللنظام
الطبي القائم يعني
هؤلاء الجرحى والقتل لا يتم من خلال
الكلام عن وقفه اطلاق النار نقطه اخرى
تتعلق بضروره ان تتوافر مواد طبيه وغذائيه
حتى يمكن للمستشفيات ان تعالج الجرح ايضا
يجب ان يكون وقف اطلاق النار صادرا من
الامم المتحده على النمط الذي تم فيه منذ
فتره اجتماع عقده
الامم المتحده مع منظمات اقليميه ودوليه
ذاه اتحاد الاوروبي العربيه والاتحاد
الافريقي والايجاد ومع دول اخرى ذات تهتم
بالشان السوداني مثل مصر واثيوبيا وجنوب
السودان وغيرهم
وصدر في هذا من هذا الاجتماع بيانيا
بيتحدث ايضا بنفس النمط ونفس الاسلوب
الخاص بوقف اطلاق النار والاعتبارات
انسانيه دون ان يستكمل يعني انت تريد
ساعات السفير تريد ان تقول بما معناه انه
ما يجري الان من هدنه او وقف اطلاق النار
هو استراحه قصيره
لاعاده التموضع لكل طرف ومن ثم تعيد
الامور سيرتها الاولى
تسير اسوا تسير الى الاسوا لابد ان تكون
هناك اليه للوقف لمتابعه والتدقيق فقط
اطلاق النار وايضا ما يمكن معه قلبه
مساعدات انسانيه سواء طبيه او غذائيه
للموجودين في المستشفيات وفي الخرطوم هذا
بالاضافه بالتوازي مع هذا يجب ان يكون
هناك جهد من خلال مبادره امميه ايضا بنفس
النمط الذي اشرت اليه فيما يتعلق باستكمال
العمليه السياسيه فالامين السياسيه وقفه
حتى الان انتظار لنتيجه الصراع وكان
المجتمع الدولي يقول النزاع صفي كل ملك
يصفي الاخر هذا امر في منتهى الخطوره يجب
ان يكون العمليه السياسيه تسير في نفس
الوقت مع هذا ما يجري من وقف الاطلاق
النار ومعالجه الاوضاع الانسانيه حتى يكون
لطرفي النزاع ومن يساندهم رؤيه باننا نسير
في اتجاه اولا وقف الحرب والبدء العمليه
السياسيه او استئنافها ولكن يجب ان يكون
ايضا هناك رؤيه في عمليه استئناف العمليه
السياسيه هذه الرؤيه تقضي بضروره توسيع
الاتفاق الاطاري
للقوه الحريه والتغيير هناك
بس انت تعتقد استطراضا لما تقول نحن في
اليوم الحادي عشر من المواجهات هل تعتقد
انه الوقت قد مضج لطرح مبادره للحل وجلب
الطرفين على طاوله المفاوضات ام لا الامور
لم تنضج بعد
عدم طرح مبادره حتى الان امر متاخر لان
انت تترك الامور للحرب تترك الامور للصراع
العسكري ليحسمه وليس هناك امل قريب فان
يتم هذا هذا الصراع عسكريا يجب ان يكون
هناك بالتوازي معه عوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات برؤيه جديده تعالج التي في في
الاتفاق الايطالي بتوسيعه بانضمام الكتله
الديمقراطيه وايضا الرافدين
والمتحفظين خاصه ان هناك الان نتيجه هذا
الصراع ونتيجه ما وصلت اليه الاوضاع في
السودان ان هناك قاعده مشتركه ومبادئ
مشتركه يمكن البناء عليه من على سبيل
المثال ان طرفي الصراع العسكري عندهم
استعداد وقبول بالتخلي عن العمل في الجانب
السياسي وقصره وقصر دورهما على ما يتعلق
بالامن والنظام هذا امر وانهم ايضا يتفقان
على ضروره ان تكون هناك حكومه مدنيه
ديمقراطيه وان يكون النظام نظام مدني كامل
كل هذه الامور طيب انا ساكتفي بهذا القدر
سعاده السفير صلاح حليمه مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الاسبق ورئيس مكتب الجامعه
العربيه في السودان سابقا شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه
وحول الاوضاع الصحيه المترديه جراء
المواجهات المستمره في السودان اعرب اتحاد
جمعيات الهلال والصليب الاحمر في السودان
عن قلقه بعد 11 يوما من القتال واكد ان
المنظمه تعمل مع شركائها لاعاده مستشفيات
الخرطوم الى العمل
نحن قلقون جدا بعد 11 يوما من القتال في
السودان وحتى الساعه لا يوجد اي تطور لوقف
بوادي القتال ما يزيد من التحديات
الانسانيه المشكله الاساسيه التي نواجهها
هي العجز في وجود المواد الغذائيه والطبيه
وغيرها كما ارتفعت الاسعار بشكل كبير ايضا
ننسق مع الهلال الاحمر المصري والجمعيات
الاخرى لدعم جميع المحتاجين في البلاد وفي
الخرطوم العائلات عالقه في منازلها
بانتظار الاجلاء نعمل ايضا مع الهلال
الاحمر السوداني والدولي لضمان استمرار
العمل في اكثر من 60 مستشفى وتزويدها
بالمواد الطبيه
اما فتره يوسف المديره الاقليمي لافريقي
لدى اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر فقد
طالب الجيش والدعم السريع باحترام الهدنه
ووقف اطلاق النار والسماح للفرق الامميه
والانسانيه بالعمل وتقديم المساعدات
للمدنيين العالقين
خلال اتصالاتنا علمنا ان هناك عائلات في
الخرطوم لم تغادر منازلها منذ اكثر من
ثمانيه ايام والحركه بشكل عام في العاصمه
محدوده جدا يجب ان يكون هناك احترام لهدنه
وقف اطلاق النار من قبل الجيش والدعم
السريع ايضا ساعدنا بنجاح عمليات الاجلاء
للاجانب وعليه ندعو المجتمع الدولي الى
الاستمرار ببذل الجهود وحث السودان على
احلال السلام والسماح للفرق الانسانيه
بالعمل خاصه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
والمتطوعين الذين يتعرضون لخطر كبير هناك
نداءات لحمايه المدنيين وفراقنا التي ظلت
عالقه في مكانها تفاديا للقصف تحدثنا مع
المسؤولين في جنيف والسودان للمساعده في
اعاده العمل في المستشفيات وتوفير المياه
والكهرباء
وفي اخر حصيله جرى للشبكات اعلنت نقابه
اطباء السودان ارتفاع اعداد القتلى من
المدنيين لاكثر من 290 حاله وفاه ونحو
1700 حاله اصابه وقالت اللجنه ان هذه
الاعداد مرشحه للازدياد لعدم قدره النقابه
على الوصول الى المستشفيات وذلك لصعوبه
التنقل والوضع الامني في البلاد
من جانبها طلبه المتحدثه بسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في الشرق الاوسط
ايمان الطرابلسي عبر العربيه طالبت بتثبيت
الهدنه في السودان لدعم الاحتياجات
الانسانيه
بالنسبه للجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر كل الاطراف بان
الهدنه واحترام واحترامها بالطبع ولكننا
كذلك نريد تاكيدنا بان هناك ضروره لكل
الاطراف المنخرطه بفن في في الصراع بان
تحترم
القانون الدولي الانساني الذي من بين ما
ينص عليه هو ان يتم اتخاذ يتم اتخاذ كل
التدابير لحمايه المدنيين ومصالحهم
حضرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من خطر بيولوجي
كبير في السودان وقال ممثل المنظمه لدى
السودان نعمه سعيد عابد قال ان الفرق
الطبيه للمنظمه تحتفظ بمواد داخل مختبر
سيطرت عليه عناصر مسلحه واتخذت منه موقعا
عسكريا من بينها مواد مختبريه للملاريا
والكوليرا واوبئه اخرى
تتحدث عن مقتل 459 شخصا واصابه اربعه الاف
وخمسه وسبعين اخرين لكن الضحايا اكثر
الخطوره ايضا تكمن بالمواجهات في شوارع
العاصمه واعاقه وصول الضحايا للمستشفيات
وايضا تعطيل عمل تلك المستشفيات كذلك احد
الطرفي النزاع سيطر على مختبر طبي تابع
لنا بقوه السلاح وطرد العاملين فيه
واتخذوا منه موقعا عسكريا بينما نحذر من
وجود خطر بيولوجي كبير بسبب المواد التي
نحتفظ بها داخل المختبر بينها عينات
مخباريه للملاريا والكوليرا واوبئه اخرى
قال مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه ان نقص الامدادات في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم يتفاقم وان اسعار السلع
الاساسيه ترتفع بسرعه كبيره
واضافت الامم المتحده في بيان انه بعد
عشره ايام من القتال يصبح نقص الغذاء
والمياه والادويه والوقود حادا بشده خاصه
في الخرطوم والمناطق المحيطه بها واشار
البيان الى تقارير عن ارتفاع اسعار السلع
الاساسيه موضحا ان اسعار المياه المعباه
تضاعفت بشكل كبير
مواد السودانيين مع وقف النهائي للقتال
يبقى مؤجلا وكافه الرصاص لا تزال هي
الارجح على الاقل حتى الان المشهد في
العاصمه يبدو مخيفا محل اقفلها اصحابها
بعد نفاذ المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه منها
وتوقف اسواق الجمله عن العمل ومحل
البقالات القليله التي لا تزال تعمل تكاد
تخلو من البضائع والمتوفر منها تفوق
اسعاره قدره المواطن العادي يعني بكل جهاد
لا كهرباء الامويه يمكن يشد عليه هنا
والخبز اهو
اربعين دقيقه بين اربعين الى 60 دقيقه
عشان تقدر اشيل لك
عشر عشرين عيشه
الحمد لله
حامدون وشاكرون رغم قسوه الصراع والاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه يعني
انه
في استغلال يعني حتى لو الباكو بتاع
الدقيقه الليله ب 8000 هيديك له قريبا
والسيارات هذه وكانها بلا نهايه في ام
درمان تصطفوا الى جانب محطات الوقود رغم
يقين اصحابها بخلو تلك الخزانات من اي
وقود ولو توفرت فالاسعار المطلوبه غير
متوفره
ازمات السودانيين تتضاعف مع الانقطاع
المتكرري لخدمات الانترنت والاتصالات
الهاتفيه فضلا عن شرح السيوله النقديه
واغلاق البنوك لتبقى اصوات الرصاص
المتقطعه في هدنه هشه لتزيد مخاوف
السودانيين من اطاله امد الصراع حنان
المصري العربيه
المزيد من المتابعه والتحليل ينضم اليه من
باريس الان الكاتب السوداني المتخصص
بالشؤون الافريقيه محمد تورشين سيد محمد
اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه ما هو
تقييمك استاذ محمد
لمجريات الهدنه او وقف اطلاق النار ان صح
التعبير هل تعتقد ان الهدنه صامده وستصمد
ام لا الى السقوط كغيرها
في البدل تحيه لك ولكل الساده المشاهدين
الكرام وبلا شك كاميراتكم واقول لك على
كلام بعض القنوات ان هنالك فروقات تمت
للهدنه التي تم اعلانها بالامس لكن انا في
تقديري هذه الفروقات اقل من الخرقات التي
حدثت من قبل سواء كان في هدنه العيد
والهدن التي سبقتها وان كانت قصيره فهذا
يعكس بان الان الاوضاع ربما طرفي الصراع
اما بدو يفكرون برغبتهم في التوصل الى
تفاهمات سياسيه باي حال من الاحوال اما
هنالك استقلال لهذه الهدنه في اطار الحشد
والتحشيد كما حدث في المدن السابقه الان
نحن حتى تتضح الصوره اكثر بحاجه الى مزيد
من الوقت اذا تم التوصل الى تفاهمات
بواسطه ضغوطات التي ومارستها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عن طريق وزير الخارجيه
وبعض القوه الاقليميه كان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه فضلا عن ذلك هنالك تحركات من دول
الايجاز ممثله في كينيا ربما اذا تم تجديد
هذه الهدنه اتوقع ان تكون هنالك انفراجه
وتفاهمات لكن اذا لم يتم تمديده ودخلت
البلاس في مواجهات فاؤكد لك ان الطرفين
استغلوا هذه الهدنه من اجله حجده التحشيش
وكذلك الاستراحه قليلا طيب سيد محمد ارجو
ان تتفضل بالبقاء مع عصام تقلع اعزائي
المشاهدين الى منطقه المعموره جنوب
الخرطوم تنضم الي من هناك مراسله العربيه
الريان الظاهر ريان اهلا وسهلا بك جديد
المشهد من عندك وهل هنالك التزام تام
بالهدنه ام لا تحصل خروقات
ريان هل تسمعيني
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال اعود الى ضيفي من
باريس السيد محمد تورشين السيد محمد هل
تعتقد ان الطرفين وصلاه الى قناعه بانه لا
يمكن ابدا الحسم العسكريا وبالتالي فان
الخطوه المقبله هي الجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات ام لا ما زال الطرفان يراهنان
على الحل والحسم العسكري
وبالرغم من ان المؤشرات الان اصبحت تميل
الى الى رغبه الطرفين وان كان هذا لم يتم
اعلانه بشكل رسمي او او الاعتراف بان الحل
العسكري الان فشل الطرفين في تحقيقه
باعتبار انه من اهل الاولى الطرفين
يتحدثان بان هذه الحربه ستنتهي في غضون
ساعات بالايام والان نحن نتحدث عن الاسبوع
الثاني على وشك الانتهاء فبالتالي
فضلا عن ذلك هنالك ضغوطات الان تمارس من
قبل الاداره الامريكيه وبعض الشركاء
الاقليميين المهمين واصحاب التاثير الكبير
على الشان السياسي السوداني فبالتالي ان
لم يكن الطرفان راغبان الان في في الجلوس
الى المفاوضات لكن في مقبل الايام وفجل كل
طرف في تحقيق انتصارات معلومه او انتصارات
حقيقيه يجعلهم يجلسون على طاوله المفاوضات
لكن هذا ايضا مرتبط بقدره كل طرف على
تحقيقه ولو كان مصري رمزي حتى يقوي موقفه
التفاوض باعتبار ان الاوضاع التي سبقت هذه
الاشتباكات او هذه المعارك كانت تتحدث عن
القيد الزمني او الفتره الزمنيه المرتبطه
بدمج القوات الدعم السري في القوات
المسلحه السودانيه او الجيش السوداني
ففتره العامين كانت لا لا لا تروق لقوى
الدعم السريع باي حال من الاحوال وهذا
ظاهر وكذلك القوات المسلحه لا ترغب في
اكثر من ذلك فالان هل القوات المسلحه
ستقدم تنازلاتهم الدعم السريع سيقدم
تنازلات
ان هذه المعركه بكل ما تحتويه الكلمه
بمعنى هي معركه معركه حياه او موت او
معركه مصيريه والدعم السريع لماذا لانه
الدعم السريع تعلم تماما ان اذا فقدت هذا
الظهير اللي هي هذه القوات
مكاسبها السيد محمد ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء
معي انضمت اليه الان من منطقه المعموره
جنوب الخرطوم وراسه العربيه الريان الظاهر
ريان اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد من عندك
تحديدا في خلفيه الصوره نرى يعني عدد من
الباصات ربما هنالك حركه نجوح هذا واحد
اثنين هل هنالك التزام بالهدنه بوقفه
اطلاق النار ام لا تسجل اختراقات واصوات
طلقات ناريه متقطعه بين الطرفين
فعلا هنالك بعض الاصوات المتقطعه نسمعها
بين الحين والاخر لكن هنالك بعض الهدوء
النسبي يسمح لبعض الناس بالحركه انا الان
في في لفه جبا بها عدد من المركبات
والبساط السفريه التي تستعد لمغادره
الخرطوم عدد من المسافرون عدد من
المسافرين
ظروف كثيره شحال وقود والمواد الغذائيه
وايضا عدد من الظروف طلقات ومطاردات في في
الاحياء معي السيده تستعد للسفر
وتحمل حقيبتها مرحب بك وعليكم السلام
ورحمه الله
هتمشي مصر
والله
والله قاعدين لكن المشكله
في الدكاكين بقى في شحنه في العيش بقى في
اي حاجه حتى الاندومي الحاجه البسيطه دي
كده يعني الاماني انعدم امبارح انا ماشيه
في الشارع من بيتنا الثاني دخل على شقتي
الرصاص
سكينه الدعامه بنص الحله الرصاص تحت
[موسيقى]
مسافرين الاسره كلها
يعني بقينا
ما في امان يعني ممكن الاكل والشراب نعيش
يتحمله
يعني احنا بنسمع الدونات وبنسمع الرصاص
يعني بقينا الواحد
فينا حاجه
يعني انا بشوف يعني حتى النقاشات اللي هم
الاثنين دي مفترض حلوه يراعوا للشعب راعوا
المواطنين راعوا للاطفال راعين نحن عشان
مناخيرك بنتمنى لك السلام اكيد ويتفضلي
نحن معانا سائق احد البساط
مرحبا
صباح النور
الو مرحبا
مرحبا نحن معاكم ليه قطعوا
طيب ريان اذا كان اذا كنت تسمعيني النزوح
يتم باغلبه باتجاه الحدود مع جمهوريه مصر
العربيه ام لا لا يمكن قول ذلك النزوح يتم
حتى مع دول اخرى ومناطق اخرى
النزوح حاليا هذه البساطه السفريه تتجه
لمناطق مختلفه من
السودان يعني من الولايات وهذا بس تحديدا
يتجه الى القاهره معي هذا الشاب مرحبا
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله شكلك ما مسافر
انت اول حاجه
التموينيه اغراض
عندي ناس مسافرين من الخرطوم فالوضاع يعني
معلومه يعني تعلمونها جيدا كيف الاوضاع في
السودان عدم توفر مراكز تجاريه عدم توفر
خبز يعني حتى اذا فتح
حصلته على المواد الغذائيه منتظرين في
واحد بتاع دكان منتظرينه من الصباح يمكن
اكثر من خمس ساعات حتى يفتح وحتى ذاك نسبه
للوضع الخطا حتى لو في تفتح نص ساعه ساعه
وبدون
صعوبه يعني حتى في توفير لقمه العيش
الافرام متقدسه بعضها يعمل بعضها لا يعمل
اوضاع صعبه يعني اوضاع صعبه في البلد وحفظ
الله البلاد
طيب
طب ريان عندما تجولين انت في الشوارع يعني
تفضل يمكنك ان تقوم بمحاوله
في هذا المجال وفي رساله اولا اناشدها
للسيد البرهان وحميتي ويوفر الحرب لانه
جميع المواطنين الابرياء رعبوا من تلك
الاحداث واتمنى ان تقف الحرب نعم للسلام
الى
الحضور في طاوله ان شاء الله ثانيا في
استغلال تام من اصحاب الباصات من اصحاب
الباصات التذكره بعشرين لحد اسوان حاليا
التذكره ب 300 يعني
بمثابه 300% او اكثر
فاتمنى منهم نراجعوا انفسهم ان يذكروا
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
معي ايضا سائق احد هذه البساطه
قبل ان تعيد لي
تريد ان يتحدث الجميع يريد ان يوصل رسالته
مرحبا
ما في صحف الا في ولايه الخرطوم فقط
الوقود راقد في الولايات ما في مشكله بس
ولايه كم اسعار التذاكر وصلت الان طبعا
يعني كم الراتب يعني 150 170
الاخبار بيقولوا انه 300 الف وصلت
ده كلام بتاع سماس
شكرا
اذا الجميع هنا يشكو من جحا الوغود في
العاصمه هو يقول انه بالولايات متوفره او
متوفر الوقود يقول في العاصمه نسبه
للاحداث طبعا هنا طيب
شكرا صعبه ومعقده الجميع يستعد
ابقي معي ابقي معنا يعني سنكون معك في
سياق هذه التغطيه مره جديده ريان الظاهر
من منطقه المعموره جنوب الخرطوم اعزائي
المشاهدين هذه التغطيه مستمره تصحبكم في
الساعه المقبله الزميله اطيب التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
بمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات